toute menace d' ingérence nous
soulignons qu'une telle approche ne
pourrait conduire qu'à l'aggravation des
tensions une escalade de celle ci une
fois de plus nous appelons les états
concernés à faire preuve de sagesse et
de raison et à contenir les coupables de
la violation de cessez le feu qui sont
les véritables menaces pour la paix la
sécurité la stabilité régionale une
telle conduite sabotage toutes les
initiatives de paix que nous accueillons
monsieur le président j'ai l'honneur
d'introduire le message préenregistré du
président du conseil présidentiel du
gouvernement d'entente nationale
monsieur fayez mustapha serrage monsieur
le président excellences mesdames et
messieurs que la paix de dieu soit avec
vous monsieur le président je suis très
heureux à l'entâme de mon propos de vous
féliciter et votre pays frère pour votre
élection à la présidence de la 75 ème
session de l'assemblée générale
nous vous souhaitons plein succès dans
ses fonctions vous pouvez compter sur le
plein soutien de notre délégation qui
coopérera avec vous afin d'atteindre les
objectifs de cette session je remercie
également votre prédécesseur moi ma
tijani ben day pour les efforts qu'il a
consentis pendant la session précédente
je ne manquerai pas non plus de
souligner les efforts sans relâche de
secrétaire général monsieur antonio
guterres esch qui s'efforce de réaliser
les buts et principes des nations unies
malheureusement cette session se tient
dans des circonstances difficiles et
cruelle liés à la con vite 19 qui ne
connaît aucune frontière géographique et
qui ne fait pas la différence entre les
peuples la pandémie continue de semer la
mort et menace la performance de tous
les pays y compris les pays qui
souffrent d'instabilité et de conflits
comme le secrétaire général l'a souligné
nombreuses reprises il n'est pas
possible de combattre le virus si ce
n'est à travers la solidarité une
coopération plus forte et un effort
commun pour surmonter la pandémie
mesdames et messieurs à chaque fois que
j'ai l'occasion de m'adresser à votre
assemblée
j'aimerais pouvoir vous dire que nous
sommes arrivés au terme de la transition
difficile de mon pays j'aimerais pouvoir
vous dire que nous avons surmonté des
défis difficiles et que nous sommes
engagés sur la voie de la construction
d'un état démocratique avec une
passation de pouvoir
paisible où l'état de droit les droits
de la personne et la dignité humaine
sont protégés malheureusement certains
s'efforcent de saper ses aspirations
auquel libyens ont tant sacrifié
il insiste pour utiliser tous les moyens
qu'il soit même les moyens de plus
injuste et destructeur pour saisir le
pouvoir par la force mais nous ne
fléchit sont pas dans notre résolution
pour atteindre les objectifs pour
lesquels les martyrs ont donné leur vie
ces héros de notre armée nous ont prouvé
qu'ils sont le rock qui sera capable de
tenir en échec tous ceux qui essaieront
d'imposer la dictature dans notre pays
nous avons tenu notre promesse lorsque
nous avons dit que les envahisseurs
n'entrerai pas à tripoli en avril de
l'année dernière la ville a tenu bon
face à des attaques tyrannique menée par
les agresseurs et par les milices qui
les soutiennent les dommages humains et
matériels sont trop un calcul les
incalculables pour les énoncés ici des
héros se sont sacrifiés pendant
l'initiative volcan de paix et nous
avons pu ainsi repousser cette agression
malheureusement cette agression
bénéficiait du soutien de mercenaires et
d'un soutien matériel de pays ou que
chacun connaît et qui sont d'ailleurs
évoqué dans les rapports des nations
unies c'est inacceptable cela constitue
une violation de la souveraineté de
l'indépendance libyenne ainsi que des
résolutions du conseil de sécurité et du
droit international qui interdisent
l'ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures des états ne fait aucun
doute qu'une telle
conduite ne pas être comparés aux
accords légitimes conclut par les
autorités légitimes avec certains états
alors que la situation évolue et que le
peuple les biens enregistre des
victoires peuple libyen qui est
déterminé à avancer à surmonter tous les
obstacles
nous appelons les états concernés à
revoir leur position et à ne plus faire
le pari des agresseurs mais plutôt de
s'asseoir à la table de négociations
avec le gouvernement d'entente nationale
pour essayer de trouver une solution à
leurs préoccupations
nous devons travailler à nouer des liens
fondés sur le respect mutuel les
intérêts communs et le principe de non
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
nous avons saisi toutes les occasions
possibles pour réitérer notre engagement
envers des moyens pacifiques le dialogue
pacifique et constructif qui est le seul
moyen de sortir de l'impasse
nous travaillons de façon constructive
avec les nations unies et le processus
de paix et nous essayons de soutenir les
efforts des nations unies par tous les
moyens
nous travaillons de bonne foi dans le
cadre d'initiatives pour trouver des
solutions aux conflits récemment il y a
bien sûr la conférence de berlin qui
s'est terminée récemment nous avons
lancée nous mêmes un certain nombre
d'initiatives visant à résoudre la crise
politique et de sécurité et à résoudre
les défis du quotidien de la population
libyenne nous prouvons constamment que
nous voulons la paix non pas la guerre
même si nous sommes dotés de la force de
la foi nécessaire pour résister à
l'agresseur et pour le vaincre nous
voulons éviter l'effusion de sang afin
d'unifier les efforts pour combattre la
coved 19 qui menacent notre population
nous avons annoncé un cessez le feu le
21 août et nous avons appelé à des
élections d'ici mars alain prochaine
nous avons souligné qu'un cessez le feu
durable et véritable nécessite que les
régions de chauffera et de syrte soit
débarrassé d'armes des milices
étrangères et des forces étrangères qui
doivent se retirer du territoire libyen
voilà comment nous pourrons garantir la
souveraineté nationale sur la totalité
du territoire les biens ans est un don
du gouvernement d'entente nationale nous
nous félicitons de soutien très large
dont bénéficie cette initiative et nous
espérons que des mesures pratiques
pourront rapidement être appliquées nous
espérons que l'autre partie acceptera
cela et se retirera des régions
mentionnées les milices doit retourner
dans leur pays et les champs pétroliers
et les ports doivent pouvoir rouvrir
il avait été fermé à cause d' influence
extérieure avec des pertes estimées à 9
milliards de dollars qui viennent
s'ajouter à des dommages graves causés
aux infrastructures
nous nous sommes félicités de la
déclaration des leaders politiques à
l'est de la libye qui ont appelé un
cessez-le-feu et à une reprise de la
production pétrolière
cependant la coopération de la part des
groupes armés et des milices agresseurs
restent encore à établir
nous tenons ces groupes responsables
toute confrontation militaire et de
toute victime ou destruction qui 1
seraient causés par ces agressions
mesdames et messieurs nous nous
efforçons sincèrement d'améliorer la vie
des libyens d'améliorer nos performances
de limiter la prolifération des armes et
de l'insécurité souvent à travers une
coopération avec la mission d'appui des
nations unies en libye des progrès
tangibles ont été faits mais ces efforts
ne sont pas viables à cause des
interventions extérieures et de la
division de nos institutions ainsi que
l'absence de production de pétrole qui
est notre source de revenus principale
nous avons toujours su que surmonter
tous ces défis reposait dans la
formulation de politiques parent et le
gouvernement élu d'entente nationale
c'est pourquoi nous réitérons notre
appel à un accord sur des fondements
constitutionnelle et l'organisation
d'élections présidentielle et
législatives
nous espérons pouvoir compter sur un
soutien fort de la communauté
internationale nous comptons également
sur la contribution des nations unies
qui doit fournir les conditions
nécessaires à des élections réussies des
élections que les libyens attendent
depuis trop longtemps
de telles élections mettre un terme à la
crise de légitimité pour atteindre cet
objectif nous estimons qu'il est
nécessaire de reprendre le dialogue
politique et d'impliquer tous les
acteurs sur le terrain toutes les
factions et partis politiques toutes les
régions tous les secteurs de la société
quelle que soit leur affiliation ou leur
idéologie
la seule exception étant toute personne
dont les crimes ont été prouvés
juridiquement et qui ont causé des
effusions de sang libyen
mesdames et messieurs nous réaffirmons
notre engagement en faveur de la
promotion de la protection des droits de
la personne et à cette fin nous avons
adopté un certain nombre de lois il
malgré les défis que nous connaissons
nous essayons de nous conformer aux
obligations internationales
à cet égard nous examinons actuellement
la possibilité d'accéder à davantage de
traiter de conventions de promotion des
droits de la personne
nous attachons également de l'importance
à la promotion des droits des femmes et
l'égalité entre les sexes et nous
continuons de fournir un accès gratuit à
l'éducation à la santé à tous nos
citoyens
les agressions contre tripoli
constituait une violation grave des
droits de la personne à cause des
pilonnages destruction assassinat un
déplacement utilisation de mines
exécution et tout cela a testé par la
découverte de charny en dehors de
tarouma après la fin de cette attaque
toutes ces violations graves mérite une
réponse du conseil des droits de l'homme
à notre demande le conseil a formé une
commission denquête mesures dont nous
nous félicitons et nous nous disons prêt
à coopérer à faciliter le travail de
cette commission
nous appelons également la commission à
enquêter sur les violations commises
contre les citoyens à syrte par les
milices du général haftar dernièrement
un homme a été arrêté et exécuté devant
les yeux sous les yeux même de sa
famille le gouvernement d'entente
nationale est déterminé à protéger le
droit d'expression de ses citoyens un
droit consacré par la loi
nous devons là
donner la possibilité d'exprimer leurs
demandes légitimes de conditions
d'existence meilleur de meilleurs
services et une faim la corruption
nous n'autoriserons pas que ce droit
soit foulé aux pieds
mesdames et messieurs une fois de plus
nous condamnons le terrorisme sous
toutes ses formes et nous soulignons que
ce phénomène ne doit pas être imputée à
quelque religion ou fois que ce soit mon
pays a consenti de grands sacrifices
pour éliminer les organisations
terroristes et un certain nombre de
combattants touristes étrangers dont des
gens qui venaient de l'ex-star de la
libye qui menaçait non seulement notre
sécurité notre stabilité mais également
nos ressources naturelles dèche qui
essayait d'utiliser nos ressources pour
à partir de notre territoire mener des
opérations néfastes nous avons ratifié
toutes les conventions contre le
terrorisme et nous considérons que la
stratégie antiterroriste mondiale des
nations unies et ses quatre piliers
comme le cadre juridique le plus
important pour faciliter les efforts de
lutte contre le terrorisme à travers la
législation nationale la promotion de la
coopération régionale et internationale
cela reste le meilleur moyen pour
traquer les réseaux terroristes et les
éliminer je dois à cet égard mentionné
la nécessité de soutenir des programmes
régionaux et infra régionaux parmi
lesquels la coopération de la libye avec
certains des pays voisins
des opérations de contrôle des
frontières en conjointe pour pouvoir
arrêter les terroristes
mesdames et messieurs mon pays continue
d'apport d'un corps des de l'importance
au phénomène des migrations irrégulières
nous continuons de gérer les flux
importants de migrants qui s'expose au
danger des trafics illicites d'êtres
humains nous avons tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé auprès de la communauté
internationale à un problème que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui personne n'a réussi à
résoudre en tant que pays de transit la
libye connaît des conséquences de
sécurité socio économique très forte à
cause de ce phénomène qui a exacerbé
notre instabilité a eu une incidence
négative sur notre société
il est difficile de traiter en selle un
sujet sans une aide extérieure
qui soit à la hauteur du défi nous
espérons davantage de consultations avec
les organisations internationales avec
lesquels nous travaillons pour atteindre
pour plus d'obtenir une connaissance
plus fidèle de la situation des migrants
en libye
nous ne pensons pas que des informations
exagérées ou inexactes soit d'une grande
aide pour résoudre la situation ces
rapports ne sont pas d'une grande aide
puisque il met à l'index les autorités
du pays sans mentionner les eaux fort de
ces autorités de défendre les intérêts
des migrants ces rapports néglige le
fait que 100 cent mille migrants
irréguliers vivent de façon paisible
parmi les citoyens libyens travaille
dans différents secteurs et envoie des
fonds dans leur pays d'origine à leurs
familles
actuellement la communauté
internationale est d'accord sur le fait
que le phénomène migratoire a plus
important que les capacités de quelque
pays que ce soit la libye est plus
grande que l'immigration ce n'est pas
notre raison d'être nous réitérons que
la solution idéale serait de travailler
sur les causes profondes des migrations
la communauté internationale doit aider
les pays d'origine et les encourager à
appliquer des programmes de
développement efficace et à améliorer la
performance de leur économie
davantage doit être fait pour faire
reculer la pauvreté le chômage et tout
les problèmes qui y poussent les gens à
se lancer dans un voyage pourtant
tellement dangereux mesdames et
messieurs mon pays accorde une grande
importance au désarmement et au maintien
de la paix de la sécurité
j'en veux pour preuve notre
participation active aux discussions sur
ce point et le fait qu'une soyons partis
qu'auteur de nombreuses résolutions sur
ce sujet nous continuons de respecter
tous les traités et conventions
pertinents nous comprenons que la
production et le stock d'armes de
destruction massive est une menace pour
la sécurité internationale est une
source de préoccupation pour toute
l'humanité
nous participons également
aux efforts de désarmement pour les
armes de destruction massive et pour le
maintien de la paix de la sécurité
internationales monsieur le président
cela fait cinq ans que nous avons
commencé à appliquer des objectifs de
développement durable
il est préoccupant de constater que la
coved 19 hypothèque que les progrès
accomplis jusqu'ici et entrave
l'application du programme en libye nous
continuons d'être en butte à des
difficultés importantes pour réaliser
ces objectifs parmi lesquels
l'instabilité politique dans notre pays
chacun sait qu'il ne saurait y avoir de
développement sans sécurité et pas de
sécurité sans développement
nous espérons pouvoir surmonter ses
difficultés pour pouvoir appliquer nos
programmes de développement 1 pour
pouvoir réaliser les eaux d'aider la
mobilisation des ressources nationales
est nécessaire
beaucoup des fonds de la libye ont fui
le pays et c'est pourquoi nous appelons
aux états vers lesquelles ces fonds ont
été détournés à nous aider à les
récupérer
nous aimerions à cet égard faire
allusion au fonds et biens gelés du
fonds souverain libyen gelé depuis 2011
à cause des sanctions du conseil de
sécurité
nous insistons sur le fait que le but de
ces sanctions est de protéger les biens
et les fonds libyens et non pas
continuer de les diminuer en fait ce qui
se passe dans la réalité c'est que nous
enregistrons de grandes pertes à cause
du gel de ses avoirs
nous avons donné au conseil de sécurité
des données depuis mars 2016 sur les
pertes que nous avons subies nous avons
demandé un amendement du régime de
sanctions malheureusement nous n'avons
pas obtenu de réponse à cette demande
légitime
monsieur le président ma délégation
soutient les réformes
emmenée par le secrétaire général des
nations unies malgré les progrès
accomplis
l'organe le plus important de
l'organisation le conseil de sécurité
n'a toujours pas été réformé or il est
important de réformer ce conseil qui ne
reflète plus
les équilibres du 21e siècle la
situation géopolitique nous impose une
réforme du conseil pour une
représentation plus équitable
nous soutenons la proposition aux
visions à corriger l'injustice
historique faite à l'afrique en lui
accordant les sièges proposés dans le
consensus d oloumi et dans la
déclaration de syrte
c'est à dire deux sièges permanents avec
tous les droits qui y sont associés et
cinq sièges non permanents
supplémentaires
cette demande constitue un minimum pour
corriger l'injustice infligée à notre
continent
à cet égard nous soutenons la demande
présentée par le groupe arabe en vue
d'obtenir un siège au conseil
mesdames et messieurs la paix au
moyen-orient ne pourra pas être réalisés
tant que des puissances occupantes
continueront d'occuper le territoire
palestinien et continueront de créer des
colonies et menaceront de mesures de
blocus supplémentaires les résolutions
sur cette question continue d'être
méprisés alors nous nous rallions aux
palestiniens qu'ils rejettent les
pratiques de la puissance occupante
nous demandons avec eux la création d'un
état indépendant avec jérusalem pour
capitale
nous rejetons également toute tentative
de détourner la question palestinienne
pour servir d'autres intérêts sans
consulter les palestiniens eux mêmes
nous continuons de soutenir l'idéal d'un
état palestinien pour conclure
j'aimerais souligner qu'un état
démocratique et l'aspiration qui a
poussé les libyens à se battre c'est ce
que nous souhaitons libye nous aspirons
à vivre dans un état où le pouvoir
puisse être transmis de façon paisible
où les droits soient respectés et où la
primauté du droit soit acquise en état
qui vivent dans la paix qui se développe
qui coopèrent avec ses voisins qui
renonce à l'extrémisme et au terrorisme
la libye possède les capacités
nécessaires pour réaliser cette
aspiration
les libyens sont capables avec la
coopération et l'aide de leurs amis de
bâtir un avenir prospère
nous espérons que nous pourrons
rapidement mettre un terme à la phase
actuelle extrême
heureuse et pouvoir transformer la libye
en un état démocratique plurielle qui
respecte la diversité culturelle ainsi
que la primauté du droit merci monsieur
le président au nom de l'assemblée
générale je remercie le président du
conseil de la présidence du gouvernement
d'entente nationale de la libye pour
l'allocution qu'il vient de prononcer je
donne maintenant la parole à la
délégation de chypre pour l'introduction
de l'allocution du chef d'état